ils ont commencé dans leur ferme de
Descartes il y a plus de 20 ans ils sont
ensuite débarqués à la capitale
remplissant l'Olympia et maintenant Fort
Boyard mais où s'arrêteront les bodins à
l'occasion du 29e anniversaire du fort
le dieu comique a été a été invité par
le Père Fouras en personne pour animer
une nouvelle épreuve cet été leur
mission faire tourner les candidats en
bourrique explication Sephora Dahmani
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Père Fouras incroyable pour faire
l'état le bal des bodins on s'amuse
comme des gamins
star de Fort-Boyard cet été les bodins
sont plus une minute à eux pour la 29e
édition de l'émission le duo comique
originaire de des cartes en Touraine a
été sollicitée pour animer un jeu de
chaise musicale
comme partenaire et pendant ce temps là
il danse contre deux candidats et les
chaises musicales en fait le principe
c'est que il y a trois chaises pour
quatre personnes celui qui trouve pas sa
chaise et éliminé jusqu'à temps qu'il
reste qu'une seule personne avec plus de
2 millions de fidèles à chaque émission
Fort Boyard va offrir une très belle
visibilité à nos humoristes mais au-delà
de l'exposition ce qui a touché Maria et
son fils c'est le symbole de l'émission
ça veut dire que les producteurs de
l'émission qui nous avait vu en
spectacle au Zénith à Paris et après
dans différentes émissions de télé on
considérait que nos personnages étaient
un peu à l'image de l'émission des
personnages emblématiques de la France
multigénérationnelle de la France qui
parle à tout le monde aux enfants aux
adultes aux anciens et nous ça ça nous a
beaucoup touché les plateaux télé les
plus regardés aujourd'hui fort Boyard le
succès des Bodin's n'est pas prêt de
s'arrêter
spectacle Les bodins grandeur nature
jouer cet été à la ferme de Descartes et
programmée jusqu'à 2020 avec déjà
plusieurs dates à guichet fermé
dans une minute de pinard